hello ladies and gentlemen rejects this
is Gregory Alba this is John so today um
you know I should get deemed every time
I say so today I'm sick of saying that
in the beginning of videos and I'm doing
me every time I say like the thing is or
like for yeah no I was actually looking
at the analytics earlier and I saw that
in the past month we've got a lot of
Indian subscribers the most gain
subscribers we've had outside of the
United States is actually India and I
think that's really cool
which makes sense was we beginning a lot
of Indian trailer requests check out
some trailers thank you normally don't
check out an Indian movie unless I'm on
my brother's channel usually just
reserve that time too for him but I said
no he lives too far away I can't drive
eight minutes all the time wait for I'm
just gonna do this with my friend John
um so I saw the first trailer for this I
did show John the first trailer at some
point for the movie ship vibe and I
think it might already be out in the US
and limited release so I'm not sure but
I do want to watch this trailer I don't
know if there's subtitles on this one
but um piece it together this is one of
those storytelling from what I gather
from the first trailer this is a movie
about a man who not sure if it's looks
like his daughter he gets kidnappers
family gets killed one of the tube not
sure but it's more about like how this
guy who's like a family man is morphing
into a killer and like an action kinda
hero
Liam piece yeah anytime a dad has
becoming a hero in some way people just
immediately assume taken is the
originator of that boy yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah I remember its ownit started that
right it invented at didn't invented
fathers having their kid my brother
you've met I had or not pronounced as a
I'm sorry guys I'm not good at
pronouncing names that I'm sucking
appereance in American names good luck
here with me a Jew edge I died Devin I'm
not sure how to say it someone just
sounded out in the comment box
dojo GUI which Google he just cannot get
go yo damage
what's a decent acacia fakie cheese
don't I'm family need no jokin artistic
you wish kiddo
Jonas aromatic they're gonna get well uh
magic is in the kitchen they made up us
already puts into your head bunny be a
good night
damn you got some style yes sir
let me shot out there whoa
whoa
Oh
look easy
oh poor Lambo it's a great car
oh it's just coming out today
now that's a cool shot
look what you Bachman Wow
his family died thank you for the great
response to the first rail adoption I
know pathetic the second trailer hope
you will like that too
she was releasing on the 20th of October
so go ahead and book your tickets now
very very happy Diwali to all of you all
I should buy ugly Peabody catch this
trail just in time take some time tell
me your whenever I get Hornets on the
weekend so maybe after or nights is done
which take some time while actually
watch his movie yeah he like wrote and
directed and storing this right is this
that one and I read and directed it I
don't think he's starring in it though
based off the trail no yeah no you wrote
directed star produced he's hardcore
promoting this film yeah I mean this
this looks crazy ain't like it the only
thing I would have made this trailer
cooler is if we had some subtitles and I
even typed in an Shivaya trailer to it
subtitles couldn't find any for some
reason at the same time though I do love
when I see a captivating trailer and I
don't know what they're saying so it is
kind of like watching a trailer without
a dialogue for someone like us people
like us who haven't actually don't
understand the language
leann you're just you're just being
given the story in a visual sense you
kind of interpret that's what's always
interesting about you know foreign
language movies anyways you have to
interpret I love the way you plays
around with the frame rates I think a
lot of this I think a lot of the just
the framing of the shots is beautiful oh
yeah there's a lot of gorgeous
cinematography throughout this whole
trailer
yeah really striking images and you know
visual composition roofing I love the
fact that you can actually see the
action scenes that you can see the
action of what's going on it doesn't
feel like crazy handheld chaos whenever
I'm seeing something happen like I can
easily see something go whoa that was
[ __ ] sweet oh that looks really cool
it's like action cinema yeah
I like it but with a real emotional kind
of character here you know it reminds me
more of a of a John wick than a yeah
yeah it's a Jason Bourne or Jason
Statham you know yeah yeah it's like
there's much more emotionally involved
in this situation because this is family
at hand but even Liam Neeson seemed kind
of you know still cold and taken well
you know he's still he's a badass to
have but he seemed like he was just
gonna get the job done you know yeah
like I know how to find you I'll just go
to France and figure it out yeah it's
supposed to here like this seems like
this is taking a toll on him this is
really wearing him down yes this looks
like one of those movies where you're
gonna spend a lot of time and I'm just
guessing but you know spend a lot of
time with the characters and really
seeing the impact like you know why this
personal mission is so personal yeah
because that's what's cool about this
trailer too is like there'll a lot of
really cool striking action shots but
like this stuff it seems like they're
spending time showing you and like
letting play out a little bit as like
emotional bits yeah I think even the
music over the trailer was really cool I
felt like I was just watching a music
video yeah that was I was allowing us to
sort of put together what this film is
all about and I love that feeling I feel
emotions being generated yes I'm
watching this more than let's get to the
next cool shot like I feel like
throughout it'll always be visually
captivating and it's it's really uh
challenging like what he's doing
especially at that lot that shot where
he was having a breakdown that wasn't
like he was shedding a few tears or had
watery eyes this guy's writing and
directing he's managing a whole crew of
people in the framing the shot to do
this this action okay let's do this a
couple yeah it's daunting to just do one
or two this is nothing like to allow
yourself to be able to get there out
when you're the one calling all the
shots on set on everything orchestrating
this like Orchestra what's a symphony I
don't know the cool metaphor is the
savings I think you can just use
orchestrating as a verb and then you
know
introduce the sentence normally because
orchestrating is hyperbolic enough right
so he's orchestrating an orchestra do
you know what I mean
yeah well yeah I mean this movie has a
very confident visual style you know
like it really looks like it knows how
to be I gotta say they look super fly
when they're going up this now yeah till
I did everything in this movie looks
really cool and and I'm talking about
his style yeah this fashion sense yeah
like totally cool he's a hot guy he's
got a bangin hot wife I'm not gonna say
anything about the daughter because I'd
be weird
um much shame to say any she's not ugly
I'm not gonna say she's a track of
either that's weird
right yeah totally you could say that
she's pretty she's pretty and she's cute
for a kid yeah cute kid there you go Oh
cute kid good character right but even
this is one shot like I didn't even
notice it at first I hear the sound
effects of it when they're running on
the side of the mountain it looks like
and it looks like there's like bullets
flying at them that's a cool shot yeah
there's a really cool jobs in here and I
was telling John today no last night
which was technically today because I
was like 4 in the morning
yeah we were athle how my favorite kind
of films tend to be action films that
are also films with a lot of heart and a
lot of story to it you know I like a
good good emotional action table and I
feel like this is the kind of movie for
me yeah it feels like one of those not
to borrow the name for the movie but one
of those like righteous killer movies
where it's like you're on you're with
this guy for the ride on you you feel
justified in taking the fantasy with
them yeah like a John wick where you're
like yes I want to see you do your job
you know it's not conflicting to me at
all it's like that yeah that looks like
kind of movie this is just identify with
this character
yeah shevai character you know like I've
been there have you oh yeah when you
were watching Leon no I'm talking about
my real life Jonathan yeah when you're
watching Leon the pre last time I went
ice climbing in the snow
what's a goal but I do it all the time
I do so much I don't even got to know
its color how was it it's not about
titles or labels is about doing Mandy a
mad at people that have shot at me and
my family and my bang and hot wife with
my soon-to-be hot daughter
that's a donald trump code sorry guys we
got a lot of things going on in america
um soon a terrible and that's like
someone's gonna trademark that and use
it
hey way anyway uh yeah we'll probably
make some time to go watch that movie
how cool to watch us in the actual
theaters not wait for it I'm like DVD or
something but actually go to the
theaters I'd probably do that yeah this
looks really cool this this seems like
it's a cool time for action cinema right
now because like a lot of movies from
all over the world are you know kind of
gaining worldwide notoriety and you know
it's like we had mechanic to
resurrection be kidding dude and Greg
too but like it seems like a lot of you
know really cool interesting action
movies are popping up from all over the
world and I'm excited to see you know
one from the Bollywood side cuz most of
all I would move ease I've seen her or
the more like musical ones and this
looks like a really straight ahead like
you know not [ __ ] around actually
based off of the other they don't really
have different music over it and just
going off of the fact that the songs
tilly different here I feel like there
will be a lot of scenes that are really
edited to the music choices yeah yeah
yeah kind of like a music video yeah so
I still feel like music will play an
integral part to the experience of this
film the show for show it's an American
term for my balls the show representing
America over here the intelligence I
assured Lee yes surely means a surely
John yeah show means my balls
cool now the frame is better after the
video is done you're new to the channel
you can subscribe today become a reject
but you're also accepted isn't that
weird
John has reasons to Jerry as a Facebook
social media manager of real rejects in
bloom house you've done a lot of cool -
speaking of bloom house we are finished
shooting a short film very late at night
that will be going up on bloom houses
social media when it's done aiming for
this weekend got about a hundred eighty
takes to look through and about a
hundred more of audio syncing to do
before I can officially start editing
this video yeah almost midnight tonight
anyway we're gonna be doing this to keep
a lookout for that